[Music]
[Music]
good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now as g7 foreign
ministers
meet for face-to-face talks in london
today there's a renewed focus on how the
world's richest nation
should be providing covered vaccines to
countries that need the most
we'll talk to the international trade
secretary liz truss
in just a moment also this hour ahead of
his first electoral test as labour
leader this week sakia starma joins us
at half past seven this morning also
today getting back to business but does
the hospitality sector need breathing
space before going back to paying
full rent at half past eight we'll
discuss calls to use a rent reprieve
system that's helping businesses
in australia and light
in the darkness at a quarter to ten
we're joined by the award-winning
astrophysicist
who took the first ever picture of a
black hole
it is tuesday the 4th of may a new
sobering milestone in india's coveted
crisis
total cases past 20 million on the day
boris johnson
and the indian prime minister hold talks
on the global response
bill and melinda gates whose charitable
foundation has spent billions fighting
global diseases
including kovid announced they're
getting a divorce
the latest from mexico where 15 people
have died and at least 34
are injured after a metro overpass
collapsed
relief for care home residents in
england who can now
leave their home for outdoor meetings
with family
without needing to quarantine on their
return
atlantic low that brought yesterday's
wind and rain has moved away eastwards
but it's left us with a chilly wind
sunshine and showers details for the
rest of the week coming up before half
past
a very good morning to you boris johnson
will hold talks with
the indian prime minister today after
india and now the epicenter of the covid
pandemic passed
20 million coronavirus cases
the uk is facing new calls to use its
presidency of the g7
to prioritize the equal distribution of
covid vaccines to countries like india
which are in the most desperate need it
comes as india's healthcare system
struggles to cope with nearly three and
a half thousand
more deaths reported this morning well
let's talk to our special correspondent
alex crawford
who's in new delhi for us this morning i
mean clearly a
dire situation alex
terrible situation the indian health
service was
not very robust in the first place and
this has completely overwhelmed it so
there isn't
a city a town or a village that hasn't
been very very badly affected by
overwhelming numbers of sick people the
world health organization
mentioned that just in the last month of
april
there has been more coronavirus cases
throughout the
world largely because of india and
brazil than there were
six months previously during the
pandemic and
india is setting global record highs in
the number of daily infections
every day it has done pretty much for
the last 12 days now that is staggering
and means that this hospital one of the
ones that we've spent
a day in uh is come utterly overwhelmed
with the number of people coming into
its emergency department for the number
of people
in it needing intensive care treatment
there are so many beds inside
their icu that the nurses can barely
squeeze between them
and as the deaths mount up the only way
that you can get into that
icu is if someone dies and there's a
spare bed they are
but people in the emergency department
are sometimes staying there for
five six days one of the nurses told me
she had five people collapse
whilst in the emergency department
waiting to be taken
to icu another two arrived here at the
emergency department
already dead so people are struggling
all over
the capital there is not enough oxygen
or at least
the oxygen supplies are not getting to
the hospitals you have we have cues and
queues of people
waiting outside trying to buy oxygen and
even though overnight they had
the indian government organized what
they calling the oxygen express
a train load of six huge liquid oxygen
cylinders for the capital we've already
had sos from various hospitals
around the capital this morning and
these are non-covered hospitals one was
from a children's hospital a non-covered
children's hospital which is finding it
needs oxygen and it's running out of it
so this is having a knock-on
impact there are not just coronavirus
deaths there are deaths from lack of
oxygen
and the supply chain literally crumbling
okay look alex will talk to you a little
bit later on for now thank you
well three large union bodies have
written to the international trade
secretary liz trust today calling on the
uk to use its g7
presidency to increase vaccine supplies
to countries
like india which are most in need and
liz trust joins me now good to see you
this morning
good morning clearly when we look at the
situation in india it is absolutely
dire what more can we do well it's a
heartbreaking situation in india and my
heart goes out to the people of india
and the
severe problems they're facing the
united kingdom has already sent
600 pieces of equipment out we're
sending oxygen out
and we've got another shipment going out
this week as well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies
it needs and of course india was of huge
help to the united kingdom
last year making sure we had the
paracetamol we need they're a close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aid have said
now that most british people in
high-risk categories have been
vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already part of the kovacs
programme which is about supplying
vaccines around the world with the third
largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary licence and i'm working very
closely with dr ngozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply as much as possible of
course to continue with our vaccination
program here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across the
world but in terms of india
the major issue is oxygen that is our
focus that is the
uh product that we're getting out to
india as rapidly as possible because
that is the immediate issue they're
facing
but i have a call later today with my
indian counterpart
we're talking about the free trade
agreement negotiations but we're also
talking about
what more we can do to help this
immediate crisis in india
in in terms of of the trade deal which
has been announced today i mean
it is significant you're looking at a a
billion pounds of new
uk india trade and investment that is
being announced today
that is hugely significant but why is it
not a free trade deal
so first of all you know this is a
significant announcement it's going to
mean 6 000 new jobs
in the united kingdom uh including
areas like vaccinations so we've got the
serum institute of india
investing more in the united kingdom
there are also going to be more
opportunities
in india because this is about a win-win
for both countries it's about helping
india
with the immediate cavite crisis but
also helping india build back
better after the covered crisis we will
start negotiations on a full free trade
agreement this autumn
of course free trade agreements take
longer what this is
is this is the immediate gains that we
can get for both countries
uh driving jobs and growth here in
britain and in india
how quickly do you think that you can
work with with this in place
how quickly can you then work towards a
free trade deal
we want to launch negotiations in autumn
we want to get those negotiations
completed as soon as possible but of
course
we'll be looking for early wins that we
can gain for both countries so for
example there are currently very high
tariffs on cars into india
on products like whiskey into india we
want to see those tariffs lowered or
removed
to benefit industries here in britain
and similarly
there are products from india that we
want to see here in
the united kingdom and if you think
about it india is the world's largest
democracy
it's a rapidly growing economy
currently our trade is 24 billion we
think we can double that
by by 2030 and this is where britain
needs to be we need to be trading
with those fast-growing parts of the
world to the benefit of british people
right across the country
can i ask you about the allegations
still circling around number 10 because
obviously we're we're now in an election
week got the local elections
uh on thursday how damaging
do you think these allegations are in in
the run-up to a local election
well i've been out campaigning uh in the
elections across the country and what
people want to know
is they want to know what are my
opportunities going to be
how fast is the government getting on
with the vaccination program we just had
the announcement yesterday
we've done 50 million vaccines across
the uk
they want to know that we are on track
with our roadmap for
getting out of the covid lockdown that's
what people are concerned about and i
think these
allegations and counter rumors from
what's going on in number 10 are very
very little interest to people across
the country what they want to know
is how we're dealing with covert how the
vaccination program is going and how
we're building jobs and growth
today we're announcing these six
thousand more jobs thanks to our trade
agreement with india there are reports
though in some of the papers this
morning i mean
the times particularly saying there are
ministers
some of your cabinet colleagues who are
concerned about how this
is going to play out this week are you
one of those ministers
i'm 100 focused on my job of getting new
trade deals for the united kingdom
bringing jobs and growth across the
united kingdom getting more of our
fantastic
companies exporting their cars their
food and drink products
their i.t products around the world
that's my focus and that's what my
cabinet colleagues are focused on
and that's what the prime minister is
focused on he spends every waking hour
thinking about how we're dealing with
covid our vaccination program
and this is frankly a distraction from
those really important issues that
people care about
without looking at the allegations
particularly because
we know they've been you know the labour
party can say one thing
we're hearing another thing from downing
street they are being denied there are
investigations underway we get that
i'm not asking you to comment on whether
you think the prime minister has done
anything
wrong he's denied it but the fact that
douglas ross the the leader of the
of the scottish conservative party said
if
codes had been broken then the prime
minister should resign
as a matter of principle do you agree
with that
well the prime minister is very clear
that he's covered the cost
of these refurbishments that he's been
working with officials
that he's declared in line with the
appropriate rules
but i'm not going to answer
hypotheticals about what might happen at
some
future date what the prime minister has
made clear is he has covered the costs
i think the british public understand
that they want us to get on with the job
which is delivering the vaccine program
and making sure we recover
uh our economy after covid and that we
have the jobs and growth we need across
the uk yeah but but even if we were
posed a question in the way of saying if
any prime minister
of any that's an even more hypothetical
question i mean that's an even more hype
but there is but there is a general rule
is that if you know if
if someone breaks a ministerial code
they're expected to go and i know that
ultimate decision is made
by the prime minister but you know the
prime minister has been
very clear that he has covered the cost
of these refurbishments
if you speak to voters across the
country which i've been doing during
these elections
they fully understand they think that's
completely reasonable
okay look can we talk holidays because
i'm sure you're desperate for a holiday
like we all are do you think we are
going to be able to get away from from
may the 17th
we won't have much longer to wait uh to
get the full announcement from the
travel
task force i would suggest that people
wait for
that announcement of course we're doing
all we can to make sure that
we follow our road map that we open up
the
economy and travel gradually
but the really important thing is that
we don't move
too fast and jeopardize the progress
we've made
people will have to wait a bit longer
i'm afraid to be able to hear the news
on exactly what's happening on the
travel front but
i can assure you the government's
working very hard we say
bring it in gradually is one thing you
know there's talk of this big bang
reopening thomas cook have said their
bookings are 50
higher this week than last i mean people
are chomping at the bit
of course i fully understand it's been a
very very tough year for people
people haven't had the opportunity to
travel either within the uk or overseas
for some time people are looking to
book a holiday but i would encourage
people to wait until we make
that announcement so that we can see
exactly
what the details are based on the data
because what we don't want to be doing
is reimporting this virus after we've
done such an excellent job
in getting the levels down in the united
kingdom so
of course we fully support safe travel
we want to make sure that people have
the opportunity
but we need to be cautious and we need
to make sure
that we're not simply importing the
virus after we've successfully dealt
with it in britain
but to paraphrase leila moran who's
the head of the all party parliamentary
group on
coronavirus she said it is
crazy to look at reopening airports she
said airports
could be a breeding ground for the virus
she's very concerned
that says the group is very concerned
about bringing new variants back in
they want to see this all delayed at
this stage
well we are doing this in a very safe
way
so we've got a very strong testing
procedure in place for
travel we have a strong quarantine
regime and any further any opening up
of travel will be made fully safe and of
course that is why we're taking our time
the transport secretary is working very
closely with airports to make sure
that these procedures work but i think
it's absolutely right that once we are
able to
we do open these corridors up because
first of all
it's important for trade it's important
for economic opportunities it's
important for jobs in graveyard britain
it's important for people with family
connections around the world to be able
to
visit and and see their families
and of course if people are if we are
able to
have people go on holiday i didn't see
any reason they shouldn't provided it
safe
but that is the key uh question that the
task force is determining
is it safe which countries is it safe
with and we will make announcements in
due course
i don't think it will be too much longer
no before we make those announcements so
i would encourage people to
uh wait for those latest announcements
you see that there is a
sort of pressing issue here isn't there
we're talking on
you know potentially the 17th of may we
haven't had the traffic light system
announced yet we're expecting that on
the first so we don't know which
countries we can go to and come back
without quarantining
we don't know quite what's happening
with the nhs app and the
the covid passports or test
certification here i mean there's a lot
to cram in in a very short space of time
are you on track to do that we are and i
know my colleagues across government are
working very hard to make sure that
we've got those procedures in place and
now as has been said it we need to make
sure that we
do have the set up correct at the
airports that we do have
uh the mechanisms right before we go
ahead and make that announcement so
people are understandably you know
frustrated
you know it's been a long year that
we've faced this covered crisis but i
think this approach
of taking things gradually of making
sure that they're irreversible
has been the right approach and people
can have confidence
that when we make the announcement we'll
have everything in place
minister really good to see you this
morning nice to see you
just a reminder if you want to see any
of that again you can do or watch the
program when you're out and about this
morning
then just head to the sky news website
or the sky news app
you can watch the program on our live
blog as well you can catch up with any
of the interviews
on my twitter account as well that's at
sky
stephen let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike who is listening
to all of that
joe well lots of interesting lines there
firstly on indian occurred situation
there the minister saying another
shipment
of supplies will leave this week going
to
india not wanting to answer any
questions about vaccine diplomacy about
vaccines being given
to india or other countries merely
focusing on this covax system the uk's
third largest donor i thought
interesting on this trade story it's
around today
some trade deal signed with india liz
trust clearly pleased about that
but when is the free trade deal with
india going to be secured she said
negotiations would launch in the autumn
we've got to remember
india may want the uk to ease its visa
regulations
after we've tightened up immigration
after leaving brexit that may not be
what pretty patel and boris johnson want
to do again avoiding those questions on
sleaze
and whether boris johnson would have to
resign if he broke the ministerial code
and finally on holidays not much longer
to wait she says
we know that the task force are meeting
this week so we should know
this week which countries are on the
green list for us to travel abroad from
may 17th okay joe thank you
now still to come this morning fighting
talk at half past seven we're going to
be talking to sakir stama to discuss his
open letter to the nation ahead of his
first electoral test as labour leader
on thursday
no one should have to suffer like my
parents did the rallying call of jeremy
daubney
who's about to embark on a nationwide
cycle challenge to raise money
for the mind association and brain tumor
charities he's joining us
at a quarter tonight
and at half past nine laughter is the
best medicine
well we know that we're going to talk to
jane horrocks and samson cayo about
their new sky comedy bloods
which follows the story of a pair of
paramedics
uh now just to update on the breaking
news in the last hour and at least 15
people have died
34 injured after a metro overpass in
mexico city collapse that happened
about half 10 local time there'll be
what about six hours behind us here in
the uk i think
these are live pictures from the crash
site it happened on mexico city's metro
line
12 the construction of which has been
plagued by complaints
and accusations of irregularities
now the billionaire philanthropist bill
and melinda gates have announced
they're getting divorced after 27 years
of marriage
the microsoft co-founder and his wife
are one of the richest couples in the
world and through their foundation
they've spent
billions fighting global diseases and
encouraging vaccinations in children
in a statement they said they no longer
believe we can grow together
as a couple aisha saheed reports
they were the ultimate power couple
together they created a charitable
foundation more than 20 years ago
it went on to spend more than 36 billion
pounds
fighting diseases from malaria to polio
and more recently covet 19.
in 2016 their work around the world was
recognized by
president barack obama who awarded them
the presidential medal of freedom
now bill and melinda gates say they are
separating
in identical statements posted on social
media they said
over the last 27 years we have raised
three
incredible children and built a
foundation that works
all over the world to enable people to
lead healthy
productive lives we continue to share a
belief in that mission
and will continue our work together at
the foundation
but we no longer believe we can grow
together as a couple
in this next phase of our lives
according to forbes magazine bill gates
is the fourth
wealthiest person in the world he made
his money from microsoft which he
co-founded in 1975
and turned into one of the world's most
valuable technology firms
bill and melinda met at the company in
1987
and married seven years later well we
were engaged to be married and after
we'd taken our first trip to africa
actually a vacation we were walking on
the beach
and we committed at that point that we
were going to give the vast majority of
the resources for microsoft back to
society just
it was the right thing for us to do and
they've been vocal about the need for
vaccine equity
last month in an interview with sky news
bill gates sent
this message to the world's richest
nations
the us and the uk will be the first
countries that will have the
excess vaccines and will you know use
these mechanisms
to get them out to where the death rate
is the highest
while the couple are separating they say
the foundation will remain
intact and so too will their legacy
together
aisha zahid sky news
well let's have a look at some of the
morning's other main stories for you
and family and friends have gathered to
mourn the death of andrew brown a black
man killed by police in north carolina
in april
civil rights leader al sharpton attended
the funeral and called for police reform
and the release of the full body cam
video of the incident
mr brown's death occurred the day after
former police officer derek chauvin was
convicted of the murder
of george floyd
the treasury is offering to help about
700 thousand people with financial
difficulties
in debt the scheme named breathing space
means people will be given a 60-day
break from their creditors
while they get access to professional
debt advice
or mental health treatment
campaigners are calling on the
government to re-wild the oceans in
order for the uk to reach its net
zero carbon emissions goal by 2050 the
marine conservation society says
britain's coastal waters should be given
the same level of urgency as
reforestation highlighting that they
store
about 205 million tons of carbon
50 million more than the uk's forests
now it's a slow step towards freedom for
those living in care homes but from
today
residents in england can go out on day
trips away from home
without having to self-isolate for 14
days
on their return well let's talk to our
correspondent katarina vertotsi who's at
a care home
in greater manchester there must be a
huge sense of relief katarina
yeah there are just under 40 residents
at this care home
as you say in bury and for them
today will be the first day for the vast
majority that they've been able to step
for
outside of the grounds of the place that
they call
home there will still be certain
restrictions
around those visits for now residents
will only be able to go
on what the department of health and
social care is termed low
risk visits that means they can sit
outside in a private garden they can go
for a walk and sit in a park and they'll
also be able to
go indoors to vote in local elections
this week without them having to come
back and do
14 days isolation upon their return
but indoor visits for now if they go for
a medical appointment
those restrictions are still in place
but it is still
a small but significant step towards
a sense of normality for many of the
people that live here
let's speak to the manager of this uh
care home at stacy aston to get a sense
of what the past year has been like
um stacy a significant day i assume
one that you welcome pro hasn't come
soon enough absolutely it's going to be
amazing for
residents just to be able to go out and
see a bit of normality again
see other people see people even if it's
just a walk in the park and see
other people you know see see their
families go to
go and visit their their sons their
daughters in their gardens and
obviously not on a day like today um but
go and sit and have a cup of tea in a
garden with that with their loved ones
it's going to be amazing
and do you feel like it has been a
long time coming i mean until now if
people had even wanted to do this would
have had to have isolated for 14 days
did that seem right to you
absolutely not it's it's unfair i
appreciate that they are the most
vulnerable to coffee 19 but
you know we've got to stop living in a
world of fear and and
creating that you know the fear that
there is the fear out there but we've
got to stop
living under this this blanket rule of
of oh we can't go there we can't do this
you know these people are in
their twilight years you know so it's
really important that they get out there
and and live that life as normally as
possible
and and you would we are going to speak
to residents a little bit later i think
they're just enjoying
waking up at a nice cup of tea and
breakfast at the moment but you were
talking to us about one resident
called mr walker who's been you know
doing loops of the gardens for the past
year what will it mean to people like
him to be able to step foot
outside it'll be amazing he'll just be
able to
like said go for a walk around a local
park go
home and and have a cup of tea in his
garden with his wife
it'll be absolutely brilliant he won't
be limited to the grounds here like i
say
it's it it'll just be
so good to just open up the world again
open up their world again so that they
can get out and see a bit of normality
instead of being stuck in i mean it's
beautiful grounds but being stuck in the
grounds of the care home they can get
out and see people and
see life going back to normal wonderful
stacy a very emotional day i'm sure it
will be for all for the staff here
seeing your residents
being able to go outside for the first
day unfortunately as stacy said the
weather here
isn't looking particularly uh bright for
now but these these rights in
it's not just for today today is the
first day but it will be the small step
towards
greater freedoms now for the foreseeable
yeah katarina thank you somehow i don't
think the weather will
matter too much to those people getting
out and about but let's see
exactly what it's going to do for you
isabel morning
good morning stephen yes yesterday of
course was really quite wild wet and
windy that particular low has moved away
eastwards
but it's left us in this cold showery
air mass let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
well this opening shot really paints the
picture then this is the depression or
the area of low pressure that gave us
the wind and rain yesterday gusts of 76
miles an hour in north wales
uh that particular load putting away
eastwards northerly winds
coming in bringing showers to many
places and
fairly persistent uh wet weather as well
across some central areas
it does look as though more southern
areas could get away with at least some
sunny spells at times
and might just find temperatures get up
to about 13 or 14 on the south coast
with the winds easing a touch there this
afternoon
but many areas rather cloudy cool and
with quite a bit of wet weather as well
as those showers feed in around that
area of low pressure but later it does
look as though it'll be a bit brighter
in the far north of scotland now as we
head our way through this evening and
tonight this showery area moves
southwards
there will be a bit of a frost under
clearer skies elsewhere and later in the
night actually we'll put in some wintry
showers across the north of scotland
snow mainly up over the hills but
something to watch for tomorrow
otherwise it's one of those days where
it might start off bright and dry but
showers will break through and there'll
be further showers
on thursday as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you this is sky news
breakfast still to come we'll talk to
the labour leader
sakia stama in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
now in the last few minutes the
international trade secretary has told
sky news the uk is seeing
what it can do to increase vaccine
supply to india after the country passed
20 million
covert cases the united kingdom has
already sent
600 pieces of equipment out we're
sending oxygen out
and we've got another shipment going out
this week as well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies
it needs and of course india was of huge
help to the united kingdom last year
making sure we had the paracetamol we
need there are close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aide have said
now that you know most british people in
high-risk categories have been
vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already part of the kovacs
programme which is about supplying
vaccines around the world with the third
largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary license and i'm working very
closely with dr ngozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply as much as possible of
course to continue with our vaccination
program here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across the
world
[Applause]
well let's talk to the leader of the
labour party sakia stalmer who joins us
now good to see you this morning
are we meeting our responsibilities as a
nation when it comes to
to the pandemic well uh across the world
obviously this huge concern particularly
in
india and i think that the more we could
do um
to assist india the better and i know
the government is already taking steps
in that direction and i urge them um to
increase that where they can it's got to
be a global
um response but i think it is a reminder
that notwithstanding the successful
rollout of the vaccine here
we won't be through this truly through
this um
until across the world we've got the
virus completely under
control i think many many people will be
distressed looking at the situation
currently in india can we talk about the
the elections this we've got local
elections we've got a by-election i mean
the labour party has been accused of
being well you know
a little bit policy light going into
these elections
well uh what we've said is there should
be 400 000
new jobs created bringing forward
initiatives
due to the next five years in loco
carbon
areas um we've said there should be a
guarantee for young people that if young
people have been out of work
for six months um or so they should be
in education they should be in training
or they should have a job
guarantee we said we want more police
officers on the
beat on the streets not behind desks
and we've been very clear about bringing
down anti-social behavior and
a fair reward for those on the front
line particularly the nhs
now they've been our priorities and um
my job as leader of the labor party is
to make it absolutely clear
that i've got a burning desire to build
a better
future for our country and that thursday
is the
opportunity the first opportunity to
take a step towards that
and to demonstrate that the priorities
of the labour party that i
lead are the priorities of the british
public
but if those priorities are ones that
resonate with the british public then
the polls must make do some
disappointing reading for you
i mean you know after the obviously
there's a scandal
surrounding number 10 at the moment uh
we've got
this huge recession you know the biggest
most aggressive recession facing the g7
because of the
the pandemic which you know is
understandable
and yet you still are trading in the
polls i mean
quite significantly in some places well
you know there's no getting away from
the fact that we lost
the last general election in december
2019 very badly the worst loss
we've had since 1935 and my job as
leader late party is to rebuild our
party
reconnect with the public rebuild trust
that will take
time but the most important thing is
that i make it clear that i understand
um that every vote has to be earned it's
why i've been across the united kingdom
talking to people in different
communities been in hartlepool
three times talking about the jobs of
the
future things that really matter but um
you know i know we've got to earn every
vote
i know that we've got to rebuild out of
that devastating loss in 2019. it's a
mountain decline but we're climbing it
i mean forgive me though i mean when you
talk about hartley pool that there is
one pole out this one i missed is
it's one pole that we've seen that's
that's got labour nine points down at
the moment
yeah i've been in hartlepool three times
we're having thousands of conversations
with voters in hartlepool with the teams
that we've got there
there is a positive response but we've
got to build on that we've got to earn
every vote
in hartlepool and you know in hartlepool
the things that people
have um said to me matter most of them
there's a nuclear power plant in
hartlepool coming to the end of its
natural life and everybody wants to know
what's the next generation of jobs there
there's
750 hartlepool jobs tied up in that
power station i was at liberty steel
on saturday morning 250 people they're
really worried still
workers worried about um their jobs and
uh that is what matters most in hartley
paul it's why hartley paul
needs a powerful labor voice to stick up
for those jobs and stick up for the next
generation
yeah well again it goes back to the
question if that's what matters most and
and you think that's what labor can
deliver then why are people
not flocking to the labour party
according to the latest polls i mean
it begs the question as to whether you
have pitched things in the right way in
the run-up to this you've
you've gone all out on the sleaze
allegations
has that been the right approach well
we've put first and foremost actually
jobs
um the nhs front line and getting crime
under control and dealing with
anti-social behavior they're our
priorities
of course uh we have um
shone a torch on the sleeves because
um what we've seen um recently is
clear evidence that those at the top of
government feel that the rules just
don't apply to them
whether that's contracts on whatsapp
groups whether it's
privileged access um or whether it's
refurbishment of flats a general sense
that there's
one rule for them and another rule for
everybody else and coming out of a
pandemic
when people have really struggled for a
year or more
the idea that somehow it's priced in
that that's how
the government behaves i think is
completely completely wrong
and yet you know you're a year into the
job
you know you've got a lifelong labor
voter down in was it bristol or bath
you're throwing you out of his pub
saying you know you'd let him down as
labour leader that i mean that's a
it's a big obstacle to overcome you
don't seem to be managing it at the
moment
since you put that example to me let's
just be clear about
what the argument was about that
landlord
believed that um only old people
were dying in the virus and therefore
there was no need for a lockdown no need
for
restrictions um having
particularly since my wife works in the
hospital having seen what was happening
at the height of the pandemic with over
a thousand people dying every day i
profoundly
disagree with that now he's entitled to
his view of course he is
i am never going to agree with the view
that we didn't need
a lockdown and that the virus is only
killing old people i'm sorry
i don't you're quoted in the times this
morning as saying you will take
full responsibility for these election
results when we get to sift through them
friday morning
if you don't do well if you don't take
hartley pool if you don't make
significant inroads in the local
elections does that mean you're going to
go
well look i do take full responsibility
for these election
results i take full responsibility for
everything that the labour party does
under my
leadership just as i took full
responsibility for everything the crown
prosecution service did when i was
director of public prosecution
that is what leadership is about i am
clear that my job as leader of labour
party is to rebuild the labour party
from where we were in december 2019 with
the worst result
since 1935 into a position where we can
win the next general election
that is a mountain to climb we are
climbing um
that mountain my job is to make it clear
that the priorities of the labour party
under my leadership
are the priorities of the british people
that we will face
forgive me for jumping in i know we're
really tight for time but if you say
you're taking responsibility what does
that mean
if it doesn't work out the way you want
by friday morning
we are fighting for every vote into this
election
on thursday earning every vote that's
why i'm out
pretty well every hour of daylight
fighting for those votes alongside the
team that we've got we'll go into
thursday with a very positive
message about the change that we want to
make for our country
for the better and indicating that this
is the first step
towards that change the job of
rebuilding the labour party was never
going to be completed in a year or
so i don't think anybody realistically
bought that
but these are a very very important set
of elections for us
so kirsten good to talk to you this
morning thank you thank you
okay let's talk to our political
correspondent joe pike joe
i think the labour leader was an
expectation management mode there
saying right towards the end of that
interview stephen that he wouldn't
expect everything to have been
solved in a year pointing to the last
general election the worst for labour
since 1935 saying rebuilding trust will
take time
every vote has to be earned i'm sure
he's seen
one poll this morning a small sample
size but showing
the conservatives maybe ahead as much as
17 points in hartley pool this labour
seat
since the mid-1970s could go uh
conservative
and the reason people are looking
towards uh hartley paul was because the
only westminster seat that's up for like
the only by-election
and because we're gonna get that result
overnight on thursday night it'll
probably have
an unfairly prominent role in painting
the narrative
for this whole sort of series of
electoral events
kirsten wants to talk about nhs and jobs
say he's been positive but of course
he's also been talking
about conservative sleaze um not a huge
amount of signs yet that those sleaze
stories are really impacting the
conservative
vote but of course only one poll really
matters and that is on thursday yeah
absolutely joe thank you
well still to come on sky news breakfast
for you this morning care home residents
in england regain
some freedoms as low risk visits are
allowed
from today
now from today care home residents in
england will be able to visit
family and friends outside without
having to quarantine
on their return this marks the most
significant easing of restrictions for
care homes and the government says it
remains on track
for lifting more rules later this month
well let's talk
to dr sanjeev kanoria who is the owner
of
advania healthcare good to see you this
morning
what impact in real terms is this going
to have on residents
good morning it's a very good initiative
that the government has taken
it will improve their mental well-being
as we
know loneliness and isolation causes
increased anxiety particularly when you
have dementia so i think it's a
very good initiative that the government
has taken
how difficult has it been for your
residents to to deal with
that lack of direct contact with family
and friends
as you can appreciate when people are in
a care home
it is very depressing and very stressful
when they cannot make contact with
people whom they know
and particularly when you have dementia
it is the people whom you know which
helps you
manage your situation and manage your
emotions so i think it is very very
important
that these initiatives are being now
taken when the infection rates have come
down and vaccination rates have
increased
throughout the country and the risk of
infection we have seen
in the last second wave the number of
care home deaths that have happened
in care homes have been very very low in
particularly in our group we have seen
very few
care debts happening as a result of
corporate
and we know these visits have to be what
the government is describing as
well not just low risk actually but no
risk visits
i mean how are you going to be able to
assess what is happening when people are
out and about
there are a lot of restrictions that
have been placed within the care home if
visitors come to the care home
themselves but if people are going
outside it is
impossible to put restrictions however
because the
residents have been vaccinated and we
the risk of them coming back with an
infection will be much lower
but at this moment in time 95 percent of
care home residents have received the
first dose almost 72 percent have
received the second dose
so the vaccination has really helped
curb this infection
but we cannot be complacent the risk is
still there
there's still infection in the community
and we have to be careful
just briefly i mean do you think there
will be further are you on
on track for further restrictions being
eased by the 17th of may
yes we are and i think those will really
help us
and all the data and the statistics show
that infection rates have come down
death rates have come down
and it is important that restriction
starts to be lifted slowly and gradually
but again we cannot be complacent we
have to be careful
well let's hope this proves to be a good
day for those of you people who
are getting out and about today dr
konori good to see you thank you
thank you very much well a survey
carried out by unions and charities
warns about a third of government
maintained nursery schools are facing
cuts to staff
and services these nurseries are funded
by local authorities so
they haven't been able to access the
coronavirus relief schemes aimed at the
private sector
elena veselinovich reports
ava and george go to a government-funded
nursery twice a week
well done you're amazing this allows
their mum lucy to go to college
she wants to build a career and a
brighter future for her children
and free nursery places have enabled her
to pursue that goal
if i didn't have access then i'd have to
drop out and i wouldn't be able to go to
university
me it would have an impact on my child's
life
without it i wouldn't be able to go and
i wouldn't be able to
pursue my wanted career which is
midwifery i wouldn't be able to do it
at all without deny she she put someone
here
but maintained nursery schools like the
one her children attend are facing a
funding crisis
they're financed by local authorities so
they can't access covet relief schemes
that help the private sector
and unions and charities warn almost a
third of them are cutting staff
and services the impact of
losing these schools will hit the most
vulnerable children behind us
they have a particular role in
supporting children with special
educational mutant disability
if the nursery schools weren't there
these children might have nowhere else
to go
maintain nurseries are located in some
of the most deprived areas of the
country
but unions say they've had little or no
access to extra covet funds provided to
schools
and for those running them the work
during the pandemic went well beyond the
classroom
we were a lifeline and we were picking
up situations that families are in
so you know if families were isolated
and had no one to get
shopping we were helping them with that
and
you know sometimes you know single
parents who were isolating with their
families were on their own
and we were the only voice at the end of
the phone sometimes
for many the support these nurseries
give is life-changing
they're now appealing to the government
to support them
milena vaseline rich sky news
oh children making a mess what could be
better i remember it well
okay let's have a look at the weather
for you today with isabelle
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
well this is the low that brought us
yesterday's wind and rain that's now
eased away from the east coast and
pushing towards denmark and southern
scandinavia that allows northerly winds
to come in
with really quite cold air and there'll
be showers as well
with quite a lot of organization to the
showers across more central parts of the
country
particularly north wales northern
england into southern scotland so
persistent sharing weather here bit of
snow
for the mountain tops possible and in
the south where you will find some
showers but here more scattered with
some sunshine in between
temperatures up to 14 on the south coast
and hopefully later
the cloud breaking enough to give some
late sunshine in northern scotland but
as we head through this evening and
tonight where the showery bank pushes
southwards down to the southwest
there'll be a frost
under clearer skies in central areas and
then during the day tomorrow the cloud
will bubble up again and it's another
chilly one
with sunshine and showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast we'll bring you more on
india's covert crisis as the country
passes
20 million cases
calls for the international community to
do more